it's great to be joined today by Daniel
Clarke who is the director editor
cinematographer and sound designer today
we're going to talk about his feature
documentary behind the curve which
follows people whose lives have been
completely consumed by Flat Earth
theories or hypotheses the idea that the
earth is actually flat and that there's
a worldwide conspiracy to cover it up
Daniel thanks so much for joining me in
talking to me about this thank you for
having me so how did flatter stuff first
get on your radar at first jumped on our
radar as a production team because one
of our producers Nick andert was a he's
a reddit guy and he saw a lot of people
talking about it and like most people he
thought it might have been a troll or
people just messing around a joke but
the more we looked into it the more we
realized no it's an actual community of
people and there are a lot of people who
really firmly believe this and it's not
a joke and we're documentarians so we
decided let's look into it even further
and see if maybe there's a documentary
to be made about this subject and yeah
that's where it all started so as you
get into this and start talking to
people who have these beliefs what's
your sense of how people get pulled into
the Flat Earth ideology and then we'll
talk about how there's kind of two sides
to it two different ways in which it
manifests but generally speaking like
how does someone get sucked into this I
think in order to believe Flat Earth
theory Flat Earth conspiracy you need to
believe in a lotta you need to be
basically susceptible to conspiracy
thinking and that's not to say you're
not smart and that's not to say you're
not educated it's just saying like
you're willing to believe that people
can conspire together in large numbers
to do something bad or withholding
something from everybody else
and so a lot of people get in to it
through like 9/11 truthers moon landings
a big one especially for Flat Earth but
there's just tons of other conspiracies
and Flat Earth is kind of at the end of
the spectrum I would say okay so because
once you say so is is it common that
Flat Earth is not the only conspiracy
theory that the people you talk to
absolutely most people believe in if you
can believe that there's a worldwide
government conspiracy to cover up the
fact of the shape of our earth and you
can pretty much be open to believing any
other conspiracy that's out there
because those seem like peanuts compared
to Flat Earth what is the claim or maybe
there's more than one and that's totally
fine that the flat-earthers assert for
why anyone would want to cover up the
true shape of the earth oh goodness
well I would say that a lot of flat
earthers claim that people didn't know
the shape of the earth until the 50s
until the space program launched MIT
launched Rockets up and then realizes
the shape of the earth and from that
point on they immediately got together
the worldwide governments got together
to hide it from everybody else because
it would mean that they were wrong and
admitting that kind of wrong in this
paradigm shift would lessen the
government's power over the people so
hiding it from us seemed in the in the
Flat Earth conspiracy ideal hiding the
shape of the earth keeps power in the
governments and the the powers that be
so it's not that a flat earth versus a
spherical earth is necessary for some
other thing it's it's simply the idea
that because governments said that the
earth is spherical for a while admitting
that they're wrong would diminish their
power in some kind of general way that's
true but also I think it would it would
admit that there's some sort of creator
so if the earth is a globe and we're in
space and the Big Bang and all that
there's not a real strong like there can
be a big argument for atheism however if
we're in a domed flat creation then
there is 100 percent of creator and I
think some flat earthers approach it
from a religious angle which means that
there is a creator and you know the
firmament is referenced in the Bible and
there's a lot of Flat Earth talk in the
Bible and so it would kind of prove that
there is a
if the earth is flat in a way this is so
interesting to me because we've talked a
lot about the anti-vaccine movement on
the program and one of the interesting
things about the anti-vaccine movement
is that it has an enclave that exists on
the political right and an enclave that
exists on the political left which have
kind of come together so on the right
anti-vaccine sentiment is often
catalyzed by a skepticism of the
government as an advocate for
vaccinations on the Left it tends to be
more related to skepticism of big pharma
and they have kind of come together and
sort of unlikely allies end up ending up
on the same page is there a similar
dynamic and it sounds like you're saying
there is with the Flat Earth stuff where
there is the religious sort of side and
then there's the kind of skeptical of
government or science side yeah I would
say that's definitely true there's there
is a religious component to a lot of
people's belief in Flat Earth but there
are people who I wouldn't call atheist
because I don't think you can be if
you're a flat earther but they do seem
to come at it from a very secular point
of view can you talk a little bit about
you mentioned the dome the idea of a
food that the earth is flat within a
dome there's two primary Flat Earth
models there's the dome and then there's
the infinite plane okay can you talk a
little bit about them and whether this
is like a controversial thing within the
Flat Earth community
sure I'll try to be brief so the dome
model both models essentially for the
most part begin with the North Pole
being in the center and instead of
Antarctica being at the bottom of a
globe it's actually on the perimeter of
this circle so it's the North Pole in
the center and the South Pole on the
outside and that is enclosed by a dome
and the dome is some sort of display
system there's another belief that there
is no proof of a dome so therefore it's
possible that Antarctica is is the start
of this infinite plane that could go on
and there could be other domed planets
or other flatter earths
so to speak outside of our own and there
is a bit of a divide in the community I
wouldn't say it's a it's necessarily
50/50 but there is some sort of divide
on we don't know what's out there so we
can't say anything for sure and
yeah it's it's the dome I would say is
the most popular model so to speak so in
talking to people for the documentary
did you experience that there is or let
me frame it a different way what is the
feeling of those within the Flat Earth
conspiracy community about those who
aren't believers is it that they simply
have not sort of decided that the
evidence that they put forward is
compelling yet are they seen as more
sort of hostile enemies that need to be
dealt with what's the perspective no I
would say I mean most all the
flat-earthers just started you know
becoming flat-earthers within the past
year to three years so there's not a lot
of animosity a lot of the questions I
got was you've seen all this evidence
how are you not a flatterer yet so
they're there it's kind of like I would
say they're more interested in showing
you the evidence that they that led them
to their belief so it's it's more of a
welcoming community it's it's no there's
no with the exception of scientists and
people like Neil deGrasse Tyson and Bill
Nye there's not really like an
us-versus-them enemy situation is there
sort of like a danger that you have
identified within the Flat Earth
community associated with the belief in
the sense that for example if you
believe the science on vaccines you
understand that not vaccinating actually
presents a very specific health risk
both to the people not being vaccinated
the people around them who can't be
vaccinated herd immunity all of these
concepts there's like a very specific
health risk we can it we can associate
is there anything that you've identified
that is similar with believing in Flat
Earth conspiracies or is it relatively
benign I would say for the most part
it's it's not a harmful conspiracy to
believe in however if you live your life
without any trust in any kind of source
in any kind of government agency in any
kind of authority figure then where do
you start trusting and you know how how
can you be able to be a member of
and if you're raising family like what
does that mean for your children and
their belief and any kind of authority
figures because there's good science out
there that we should be embracing but a
lot of fighters look at most scientists
as having an agenda and having it's kind
of like the idea of anti-vaxxers in Big
Pharma like they're out there to make
money so we shouldn't trust them and I
think not having any faith in any kind
of institution is really problematic for
our existence and our success as a
society and as a race of humans what do
you think is the goal of the
flat-earthers I mean I know so like the
immediate goal would be get everybody to
believe what they see is the truth right
which is that that there's a flat earth
but imagine that they do that right
imagine that the Flat Earth or succeed
and there becomes this a consensus
arises that the earth is actually flat
then what like in other words what would
be the implications from a practical
perspective if there even are any or is
it just for them about we just want
people to believe what we see is the
truth well if there was a consensus I
think we'd start seeing expeditions to
the edge and I think that's what's
interesting about humanity is if we know
there's a dome and we know there's an
edge we're gonna go touch it we're gonna
go try to see what's past it because
we're curious humans so I think it would
kind of be you know the same was the
same as it is with space we try to set
up agencies and see what's out there so
it's not that there's sort of a
particular life-altering implication for
day-to-day lives if we simply recognize
that the earth is flat as they see it
well I would say then the trust of
government is going to collapse and any
kind of authority in NASA and any kind
of scientist is gonna completely be gone
so I have to start building that from
scratch trusting on like if for instance
it was discovered that the earth is flat
then that would everybody would be wrong
up to this point except for the Flat
Earth or so who did we trust anymore one
thing I've been thinking about is if we
think about the role of religion earlier
in the sort of history of modern humans
there was likely some kind of like
evolutionary advantage to being part of
what
ever religious group what was in your
immediate area I probably increased
cooperation and in some way it made it
more likely that you would live long
enough through that cooperation to pass
on your genes to kids so there's there's
this kind of evolutionary advantage idea
to religion at some point in in the
history of Homo sapiens do you get a
sense that there is kind of like a
similar community element and
cooperation element for members of this
particular conspiracy theory that might
apply in a sort of pseudo religious or
dogmatic sense and that maybe community
that's lacking elsewhere is found in
these beliefs yeah and I would say
that's true of a lot of things on the
internet a lot of different beliefs and
groups on the Internet
I think Flat Earth is just one of many
the conferences and the meetups that
happened that we went to very nice
everybody's having a great time there
wasn't it's not like a necessarily like
a stale environment everybody's out
there having you know pizza and beer and
just chatting up their conspiracy
theories and everybody's willing to
listen and it's a very open group so if
you're a flat earther and you go to one
of these meetups there is no deterrent
to do it again and continue being part
of this group because it's it's a
welcoming embracing community outside of
ok so I guess I have to couch this you
said it's it's not that common that the
Flat Earth conspiracy belief is the only
conspiratorial belief for most flat
earthers but aside from conspiratorial
beliefs of this kind do you find that
generally speaking the people you
interacted with have relatively sort of
well-adjusted views on other elements of
humanity like on economics for example
or on medicine or whatever else I mean
is it is it other than these
conspiratorial beliefs are there other
perceptions about the world around us
relatively well-adjusted and accurate
yeah I would say for many many of them
yes but just like with any group and
it's not even specific to Flat Earth
you're gonna find people who don't want
any part of any of that kind of
disconnecting from society but I would
say generally speaking yeah I mean they
have families that get along well their
very soul
it's not like they're just these
antisocial people who sit in a dark room
all day they're they're very out there
they've had jobs they've done a lot of
successful things and I don't I don't
really see I don't really see it as
being an issue of you know not believing
in anything and kind of being strange on
all fronts it's just maybe this one
specific thing with a history of a
little bit of skepticism towards the
mainstream what's what's out there in
the mainstream what's your best
assessment after diving into this so
fully for the time that the film was in
production what's your sense of like the
best way to deprogram or disabuse folks
of this belief and you know we could
apply this to any conspiracy theory but
since you've been dealing with
flatterers what would you say would be
the best or most likely path for people
to exit these beliefs I think you can't
it's like with any with any strong
belief and this is true of anti-vaccine
climate change and all that stuff
you can't just present facts right and
then walk you're thinking that it's
going to change their mind
so the bet the best you can really do
and this is from talking to a lot of
people about this is be kind be willing
to accept these people back into society
you know if they decide the earth isn't
flat you can't chastise them for what
they believe before you have to embrace
it okay you have a place if you want
yeah just being open to listening and
talking to them and not shoving them
away and not being mean and not
insulting them because that's not gonna
would that help you come back from any
belief you held I don't think so you
know just being shamed or being berated
is not gonna make you say oh yeah sure
let me change my entire view or should I
just stay with people who like me and
embrace me yeah that's what interesting
be I recently read Jon Ronson's book so
you've been publicly shamed on the
Internet and one of the things he talks
about is that once you're sort of
irredeemable as far as popular society
is concerned that that's actually more
likely to be damaging in the long term
and that it's important that one in many
cases although not all not be sort of
tagged with this ear edema
and it seems that that applies to
bringing people back from conspiratorial
beliefs as well yeah I would agree with
that the film is behind the curve we've
been speaking to Daniel Clarke and we
will be linking to the film really
encourage people to check it out Daniel
really appreciate you talking to me
today thank you so much for happening